President Trump himself dictated Donald
Trump juniors first explanation of his
campaign meeting with a Russian lawyer
that's according to a report in this
morning's Washington Post Trump jr.
statement was misleading telling only
part of the story the president
reportedly crafted his son's comment
aboard Air Force One returning home from
an economic summit in Europe Jeffrey
gaius is in Washington where Trump
lawyers are downplaying the report Jeff
good morning good morning the revelation
of the president's involvement is likely
to draw increased scrutiny by
investigators digging into whether the
Trump campaigns conspired with the
Russians during the election
initially the president's own personal
attorney denied that mr. Trump had
anything to do with the statement
acknowledging the meeting it was such a
nothing I really wouldn't have
remembered the meeting when Donald Trump
jr. met with a Russian lawyer at Trump
Tower last year he believed she had dirt
on Hillary Clinton but that wasn't his
original explanation you know a story
about Russian adoption and how we could
possibly help and really that's what we
shut it down according to the Washington
Post Donald Trump two years initial
public statement came directly from the
president aboard Air Force One flying
home from the g20 summit in Germany on
July 8th president Trump personally
dictated a response for his son that was
given to the New York Times in it the
statement explained that there was a
short introductory meeting about the
adoption of Russian children and that he
was not told the name of the person I
would be meeting with and that it was
not a campaign issue at the time one of
trumps attorneys Jay Sekulow tried to
shield the president the president was
coming back from the g20 as this was
going on as you know so my understanding
is that very clearly that this was
Donald Trump jr. and his lawyers the
president was not involved in that
President was not did not draft
the response the response and was cut
and came from Donald Trump jr. on July
11 Donald Trump jr. released personal
emails which revealed Russian government
attempts to help his father win the
election two days later the president
characterized the meeting as fair game
it lasted for a very short period and
nothing came of the meeting and I think
it's a meeting that
most people in politics probably would
have taken Donald Trump juniors attorney
did not respond to CBS News requests for
a comment but the president's attorney
Jay Sekulow told CBS News last night the
Washington Post story is and these are
his words of no consequence and he said
the characterizations are misinformed
inaccurate and not pertinent Charlie
thanks Jeff